[Musique]
Stéphanie Chouinard Marie Vastel Chantal
Hébert bonsoir bonsoir
étude de ce projet de loi sur les
langues officielles à Ottawa qui fait
encore parler je vous ramène à Hyères le
ministre mélo qui dit ah pas sûr je vais
voter pour ce projet de loi-là et un
échange en chambre qui vous donne le ton
entre le Bloc québécois la ministre et
Pablo Rodriguez
il reste encore des amendements à
débattre puis on va voir le produit
final il y a des amendements du bloc tu
Parti conservateur qui qui
met une complètement l'esprit de la loi
[Musique]
ou contre le président
[Applaudissements]
très clair notre engagement n'a pas
changé
pour voir le français partout pays y
compris le Québec
estivation minoritaire les acteurs du
West talent story sortent des répliques
tout aussi ridicule les unes que les
autres monsieur le Président ça c'est
des députés du gouvernement libéral
est-ce qu'ils vont voter en faveur du
projet de loi du gouvernement libéral je
vois pas à quoi ça l'inquiète monsieur
le Président parce que les bloquistes
vont voter contre ils vont voter contre
un projet de loi qui vient renforcer le
français au Québec renforcer le Québec
le français à travers le Canada
bon on sait pas si les bloqué je
m'envoie Pablo te dit dans la joue
Rodriguez ils vont voter quand ils ont
dit on va peut-être pas voter quand
Stéphanie Chouinard vous en êtes où dans
l'analyse de tout ça d'abord expliquer
aux gens qu'est-ce qui inquiète pas et
jusqu'à un ministre monsieur les
amendements qui ont été adoptés et
proposés par le bloc les conservateurs
et appuyés dans certains cas par le NPD
pour les députés dont Monsieur merlueux
et Madame lambropoulos etc qui se
retrouvent avec des portions importantes
de leur électorat qui sont de la
minorité Englos québécoise ce projet de
loi-là est vu comme un changement de
paradigme par rapport à l'ancienne Loi
sur les langues officielles où on
parlait de l'égalité des deux langues
officielles et on s'arrêtait là ce qu'on
dit dans cette nouvelle mouture et
c'était d'ailleurs le cas pour le projet
C32 qui était mort au Feuilleton c'est
que on reconnaît encore l'égalité des
deux langues officielles on reconnaît
aussi que factuellement sur le terrain
le Français a besoin d'être
supplémentaire et donc c'est là où le
bât blesse parce que pour la minorité
Englos québécoise c'est vécu comme un
désaveu d'autant plus maintenant qu'avec
un amendement du Bloc québécois ont on
veut reconnaître la Charte de la langue
française du gouvernement du Québec qui
va plus loin évidemment que le
gouvernement fédéral à cet effet là donc
c'est là où il y a une scie sur qu'on
voit au sein du caucus libéral et ça
c'est un gros désaveu pour la ministre
exploitée on se souvient bon qu'elle
avait été ministre de la Santé la vérité
démise de ses fonctions le ministère de
langue officielles c'était vu comme
deuxième chance pour elle de faire ses
preuves et là on voit que l'unité que
Mélanie jolie avait réussi à garder en
tant que ministre des langues
officielles s'effrite complètement on
perd le contrôle au sein du focus
monsieur Garnaud qui dans une note dit
les anglophones qui vivent au Québec
font partie d'une minorité il faut vous
compreniez ce que je dis bon il a fait
une explication lui ce qui ne passe pas
c'est aussi que vous l'avez expliqué
Stéphanie que la Charte de la langue
française soit nommée et que on impose
aux entreprises privées le pas public
mais privé à chaque fédéral la loi de la
loi 101 Marie vacelle est-ce que ça
dérape parce que là bon
est quand même ministre
ça dérape un peu je vous dirais il y a
deux camps dans ceux qui qui ont des
problèmes avec le projet de loi c'est 13
il y a le camp de ceux qui brandissent
vraiment cet argument constitutionnel en
disant que si on fait référence à
l'achat de la langue française qui a
depuis été modifié avec le projet de loi
96 qui a invoqué la clause dérogatoires
de façon préventive ça ça crée un
dangereux précédent cette espèce de
débat là et de l'autre côté il y a le
débat avec madame lambrepoulos monsieur
c'est vraiment comme le dit Stéphanie le
la crainte là pour la minorité
anglophone et moi ce qu'on dit c'est
qu'à l'époque où Mélanie jolie avait
déposé la refonte de la loi sur les
langues officielles en 2021 il y avait
déjà ces tensions là à l'interne au sein
du caucus du Québec mais on ne les
voyait pas au grand jour et la
visiblement la ligne de fracture là est
en train de s'accentuer où il y en a qui
sentent qu'ils peuvent avoir libre
parole et dire ce pense publiquement la
grande question je pense c'est est-ce
que le gouvernement va finalement finir
par décider ce qu'il fait avec la ligne
de partie est-ce que ces gens-là doivent
rentrer dans le rang ou pas la semaine
dernière Pablo Rodriguez disait que le
cocus est uni que tout ça était réglé
après le comité ou en comité visiblement
ce n'est pas le cas et il va falloir que
le gouvernement se branche bien tôt si
vous me permettez l'expression parce que
tout se débat là ça nuit pas mal à leur
à l'image qu'ils veulent donner d'un
parti qui défend le fait français au
Canada c'est c'est difficile de
prétendre que c'est les plus grands
défenseurs quant à l'interne il y a
autant de de chican qui déborde même sur
la place publique Chantal est-ce qu'on
veut sortir le fouet le web
parlementaire est-ce que dans le caucus
libéral il va la discipline nous on n'a
pas le choix que de laisser aller ici et
là mais je répète le meuleuse d'un
ministre lui là bon d'abord il y a une
série de ce qui est en train de devenir
des légendes urbaines qui utiliser comme
argument par exemple l'idée que on a
demandé la loi pour que la charte elle a
un française est pressé en sur la loi
sur des langues officielles c'est pas
arrivé ça a été rejeté et c'est pas dans
d'autres vont vous dire oui mais en
faisant ça on reconnaît par la loi 96
l'amendement constitutionnel unilatérale
qui dit que le français la langue
officielle du Québec j'ai vérifiais la
date là c'était en 74 qu'on a décrétique
la langue officielle du Québec était le
français et d'autre part les droits
linguistiques de la minorité
englo-québecoise sont protégés et la
clause nonobstant n'a pas d'effet sur
leurs droits alors vous me dites est-ce
qu'on va sortir de fouet et on parle du
ministre milieu je suis aussi retourné
dans mon grand livre
un ministre qui vote contre un projet de
loi de son gouvernement généralement
doit démissionner et le col le plus
récent que j'ai trouvé peut-être que
j'en ai manqué depuis c'était celui de
Joe comme outil qui était membre du
cabinet de Paul Martin qui a voté contre
la loi sur le mariage pour tous et qui
donc a perdu sa place au conseil des
ministres oui il y a des ministres de
Stephen Harper qui ont voté sur des
sujets comme l'avortement d'une façon
plutôt que d'une autre mais c'était pas
un projet de loi du gouvernement là on
parle d'un projet de loi sur lequel le
gouvernement a fait campagne deux fois
plus tôt qu'une
qui est ou non un vote libre un vote
libre de ministre sur un projet de loi
du gouvernement j'en ai pas vu ça existe
pas
non
Stéphanie Marie et chanta qu'est-ce que
ça nous dit parce que la semaine
dernière on a on a parlé la semaine
dernière ça a commencé il y en avait
trois on disait certains disaient
prétendaient que ça faisait un peu la
faire de Monsieur Trudeau parce que
c'est un peu la l'image du presto le ça
laisse aller une certaine insatisfaction
mais dans le fond on va on va voter là
est-ce que ça fait pas davantage
Stéphanie et Marie et Chantal désordre
Marie mais le presto ça va quand c'est
temporaire je pense quand ça se passe en
comité qui a un débat sur les
amendements sur la façon de modifier
bonifier changer le projet de loi quand
ça devient comme Chantal le disait un
ministre qui veut pas voter pour son
propre projet de loi ou en tout cas qui
est pas certain quand ça s'étire dans le
temps comme ça que les que le nombre de
gens qui pourraient voter contre se
multiplient je suis pas certaine que ce
soit
bénéfique pour le gouvernement là qui
peut qui peut se vanter de ne pas
imposer la ligne de de façon trop trop
sévère comme le faisait par exemple le
gouvernement Harper à un moment donné il
faut qu'un gouvernement a l'air d'être
capable de gouverner de faire avancer
son sa plateforme son agenda et là ça ça
semble mise en doute en tout cas pour
l'instant dans le cas de ce projet de
lois si je pense pas que je pense que
les bénéfices de l'ouverture du
gouvernement on
passe qui dirigent bateau là Chantal
est-ce que c'est la ministre petit
pateller ou c'est le bureau du premier
ministre ou ces personnes
parce que des fois on a l'impression que
c'est un peu personne écoutez la
ministre et c'est elle qui est
responsable du dossier aurait été toute
la semaine que Justin Trudeau avait
assuré que le projet de loi allait
suivre son cours c'est la parole du
Premier ministre qui est là-dessus mais
effectivement pour ceux qui croyaient
que c'était une savante stratégie ça
Gace on en est rendu à discuter de qui
du ministre Mark Miller qui est d'autre
part un ministre très apprécié en
passant ou de avec le blanc et le
meilleur ami de Justin Trudeau et donc
organe le plus d'influence mais ça vous
donne une idée le Dominique Leblanc
c'est un acadien
Mark Miller représente une
circonscription où il y a des Englos
québécois inquiets ils ont des points de
vue relativement des perspectives très
différentes et à la fin la seule
personne qui peut trancher c'est pas la
ministre de toute façon c'est le premier
Stéphanie vous avez dit tout à l'heure
c'est un changement de paradigme ce
changement philosophique c'est de
reconnaître que le français est
davantage menacé dans ce pays-là et
au-delà du petit amendement de ça madame
lambropoulos qui par ailleurs disait
le médecin de ma grand-mère de l'ami de
ma grand-mère veut plus parler anglais
assez patients plus droit de dire là on
est dans un peu dans la dans De la
fausse information mais au-delà de ça
c'est le choc d'un changement d'attitude
vis-à-vis des deux langues officielles
c'est un changement d'attitude sur
papier mais dans la pratique c'est déjà
comme ça que ça fonctionne dans les
langues officielles au fédérales la
réalité sur le terrain c'est qu'il y a
neuf provinces et trois territoires où
le français c'est la langue minoritaire
et il y a une province où c'est
l'anglais qui est la langue minoritaire
et donc dans la pratique ça fait des
décennies que le gouvernement fédéral
soutient plus le français que l'anglais
en matière de langue officielle en
matière de bilinguiste donc ce qu'on
fait avec la nouvelle mouture de la loi
c'est simplement reconnaître sur papier
ce qui se fait déjà et donc dans la
pratique il y a rien qui est enlevé aux
Englos québécois avec avec ce projet de
loi là donc vraiment comme vous l'avez
dit on fait de la dans la désinformation
de toute façon en matière de santé ça
n'a rien à voir avec les prérogatives du
gouvernement fédéral et Madame la
brocola c'est déjà fait s'abonner par
rapport à cette anecdote là qui semble
un peu douteuse mais ce que je trouve
fascinant moi de remarquer c'est que ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'au Canada la ligne
de partie est la plus stricte d'à peu
près toutes les démocraties dans le
monde et pour le moment on entend rien
sortir du bureau du premier ministre
quand tu as à savoir si on va
effectivement sortir le fouet ou non
donc pour pour Monsieur Trudeau là c'est
vraiment la question de sa réputation en
matière de langue officielle qui est
aussi en jeu et pas seulement celle de
Madame petit à mon avis ok alors on va
suivre ça la ministre et Monsieur
Trudeau réaffirme que parce qu'il y a
certains la semaine dernière disait ça
va être mis sur une voie de de garage on
peut pas imaginer ça ils sont allés trop
loin et ça sera un tolé épouvantable à
voir avoir projet de loi c'est simple
qui a fait je vous fais entendre à
Québec une motion une année et on
revient tout de suite
qu'elle reconnaisse que le projet de loi
C5 va à l'encontre des efforts déployés
afin de rebâtir la confiance des
personnes victimes envers le système de
justice et qu'il s'agit qu'il s'agit
d'un recul en matière de lutte contre
les violences sexuelles qu'elle demande
gouvernement fédérale de modifier la loi
afin de rendre inadmissible l'infraction
d'agression sexuelle au peine
d'emprisonnement dans la collectivité
on a pas touché les pannes une image qui
existait pour les agressions sexuelles
le cas échéant oui il y a une
possibilité de ordonnance sur soucis
selon la loi
la loi est là vraiment pour viser la
sur-réprésentation des peuples
autochtones et des Noirs dans le système
judiciaire
Marie C5 c'est un mécanisme qui avait
pour but effectivement de de
s'attaquer au problème de la
sur-représentativité dans les prisons de
toptones par exemple et on disait pour
certains délires on va encourager les
peines à la maison bon
un des un des résultats possibles c'est
que pour quelqu'un qui est coupable d'un
crime sexuel il pourrait avoir droit à
une peine à la maison je résume mais
c'est à peu près ça m'arrive assez
est-ce que on est sensible Ottawa ou à
l'argumentaire de Québec où on dit non
vous faites fausse route je pense que il
y a comme un choc de vision en fait
ce changement là au Code criminel
c'était une demande qui découlait des
recommandations de la commission Vérité
réconciliation
cette commission là sur les les
passionnants autochtones et toute cette
vision là du gouvernement fédéral et
c'est ce que Monsieur la médecine disait
cette semaine c'est vraiment de
de baisser la sur-représentation dans
les prisons et donc monsieur la médecine
qui insistait pour dire dans notre
système judiciaire il y a cette
discrétion pour les juges donc
discrétion qui peut aller dans un sens
d'imposer une peine plus sévère lorsque
c'est justifié selon le juge mais aussi
discrétion de ne pas imposer une peine
de prison par exemple parce que le
gouvernement fédéral au gouverne Trudeau
pense qu'il faut tenir compte du passé
du contexte social de certaines
communautés autochtones et autres en ce
sens là je ne sens pas beaucoup
d'ouverture donc à Ottawa de modifier
les choses surtout que le projet doit
est
nouvellement adopter il est devenu loin
en novembre dernier Monsieur la médecine
disait donne le temps aux choses de
procéder avant de de demander toutes
sortes de changements mais j'ai du mal à
avoir le fédéral s'ajuster aux demandes
de Québec parce que c'est une vision
différente de ce que devrait faire le
système de justice au final c'est qu'à
l'époque avait lutté contre les peines
minimales de rappeur en 2007
je suis d'accord avec Marie je pense pas
qu'on va se précipiter à Ottawa pour
faire une réécriture de la loi mais je
note quand même que c'est deux
projets de loi ou loi qui ont passé dans
la machine législative pendant un bon
bout de temps et sur lesquels Québec
tout à coup plus qu'à la dernière minute
arrive en disant il faut changer ça
c'est le code C5 dans ce cas-ci mais
c'est aussi le code séance ça vient
d'être adopté au Sénat et là le
gouvernement du Québec veut des
changements en séance le même
gouvernement qui par une motion unanime
de l'Assemblée nationale disait passer
ses 11 au plus vite et là on se dit
pourquoi est-ce que c'est représentation
là on n'a pas été faites par le
gouvernement du Québec puisqu'il est
capable d'en faire pour ces 13 la Loi
sur les langues officielles pendant
qu'on était en train de les débattre et
la réponse m'échappe
effectivement on se demande pourquoi le
gouvernement du Québec arrive avec ses
demandeurs un peu à la dernière minute
ce sont des dossiers qui traînent depuis
longtemps sur lesquels le gouvernement
fédéral et non ces intentions depuis
très longtemps dans le cas de ces cinq
on parlait déjà de ces enjeux-là quand
c'était madame Wilson reboot qui est
terminé de la justice donc ça date pas
d'hier et là alors que le gouvernement
fédéral approche du but on arrive avec
ces demandes là c'est un peu c'est un
peu étrange un peu tard Stéphanie Marie
Chantal bonne soirée merci beaucoup à
très bientôt au revoir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI